hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the puzzles that might arise for
a first-time reader of John Stuart
Mill's treatise utilitarianism is given
that he makes this distinction between
higher and lower pleasures why would
anybody anybody in their right mind
anybody who is experienced or perceptive
prefer lower pleasures to higher
pleasures and we want to keep in mind
first what does mill actually mean by
higher and lower pleasures so with
qualitative utilitarianism he says that
there's a distinction that we can make
between pleasures and also a way of life
that engages our higher faculties the
things that make us distinctively human
our intellectual faculties our moral
faculties he also talks about our
aesthetic appreciation of things and
that goes beyond what he calls
sensibility or
or you know the pleasures of the senses
this also applies to pain as well there
can be qualitatively worse pains and
qualitatively lesser pains here we're
more concerned with the issue of
pleasure and the way that Mill describes
it is that how do we know that that
something is a higher pleasure well we
look at those who are actually
experienced in both types of pleasures
and we see which one they elevate and
which one they put lower the way that we
actually do this is we look to see which
one they prefer in situations where they
can't have both of them because if they
can have both of them Mill sees no
problem with that as a matter of fact
from utilitarian perspective if we can
enjoy every pleasure possible that's
that's wonderful
now we often do have to make choices
prioritizations even sacrifices and then
Mill says that in a case like that
the ideal judge the person who really is
in touch with the values of the
pleasures will prefer the higher to the
lower pleasures so given the choice
between for example books and beer
if you can't have both well then you're
gonna prefer books because that engages
your intellectual faculties given the
chance to go out and have a nice dinner
party with your friends or to engage in
some socially beneficial activity you
will engage in the socially beneficial
activity because that engages your moral
faculties and we can go on and on and on
so then the question is okay granting
that why would anybody once they
experience pleasures why would they ever
prefer as it seems most people indeed do
lower pleasures to higher pleasures and
Mill has some some good answers for this
and he he considers two objections early
on in in Chapter two of utilitarianism
so one objection is that we do see
people as he says postpone a higher
pleasure for a lower pleasure they they
go for the lower pleasure which is you
know right there in front of them and
then that means that they have to put it
off engaging in a higher pleasure what
might be an example of this you know I'm
set up to read some John Stuart Mill
which should be an intellectual activity
should be quite pleasurable because he's
actually a good writer not like his
predecessor Jeremy Bentham who's very
dry to read but Mill is quite
interesting so I'm ready to do this and
then I get you know distracted by
something else I start perhaps watching
a show a comedy show on Netflix and it's
not a particularly intellectually
stimulating one it's just kind of a
goofy one and and I get sucked into this
this thing where I watch show after show
after show until I fall asleep and the
book never gets opened up now why does
that sort of thing happen what mill has
an explanation for this he says that
here we go many who are capable of the
higher pleasures occasionally under the
influence of temptation postpone them to
the lower but this is quite compatible
with a full appreciation of
intrinsic superiority of the higher men
often from infirmity of character make
their election for the nearer good
whatever is easier to acquire whatever
is closer in time reading a book right
you have to get into it and it takes a
bit of time to figure out what's being
said so he says they know that this is
less valuable and this no less when the
choice is between two bodily pleasures
and when it is between bodily and mental
so they pursue central indulgences to
the injury of health though perfectly
aware that health is the greater good
people do this in terms of bodily
pleasures why can't they do it in terms
of bodily and mental pleasures it makes
perfect sense people again do this all
of the time just think of it you know
for his example how many people sign up
for gym memberships that they will never
actually use beyond say the first week
this is how gyms make their money they
think oh this dynamic similarly we may
find that people say that they're going
to do something that is intellectually
stimulating or morally valuable or you
know aesthetically pleasing as opposed
to merely sensibly pleasing and then
they go for the the sensual pleasures
that happens the other objection is is
in some respects more interesting he
says what about younger people who early
on in their life they have in fact been
introduced to the higher pleasures and
they do pursue them the pleasures of the
mind the pleasures of the human heart
you might say and then as time goes on
as they get older something changes they
shift they they're no longer interested
in those and they focus on the sensual
pleasures so he says this is can be
understood just as well he says I don't
believe that those who undergo this very
common change he's saying that it is
common voluntarily choose the lower
description of pleasures in preference
to the higher so what's really going on
there he tells us I believe that before
they devote themselves exclude
to the one they've already become
incapable of the other it says capacity
for the noble feelings is in most
nature's a very tender plant easily
killed not just by hostile influences
things coming in from the outside but
from we mere want of sustenance and in
the majority of young persons it
speedily dies away if the occupations to
which their position and life has
devoted them and the society in which
has thrown them are not favourable to
keeping that in exercise so although we
may start out with good experience of
both the higher and the lower pleasures
unless we're actively using our mental
faculties unless we're getting the sort
of stimulation that we need and and
perhaps even engaging in some deliberate
reflection and choices to do something
with it it's going to wither away and in
a case like that the person shifts from
the higher to the lower pleasures
because they no longer appreciate the
higher pleasures as higher pleasures
what is the sign of that the very fact
that they do in fact prefer the lower
that they tell you why say sitting and
and drinking in front of the fireplace
is preferable to cracking open a book or
having an intellectual conversation or
going out and doing some you know
strenuous but rewarding activities or
listening to a symphony they'd rather
just let you know Netflix play on and on
and on while they sit there drinking
some some wine or beer or cocktails or
whatever right so you know these sort of
cases show us that Mill does have some
explanation for how people lose or don't
actuate their capacity for these higher
pleasures and then end up preferring
lower
there's also another interesting issue
which is as he sees it a major problem
with society of his time and I think you
could say that from utilitarian
perspective it's also a major problem in
our contemporary society which is that
most people do not have moral and
intellectual development fostered within
their life which makes it impossible for
them to appreciate the higher pleasures
because they never had a shot at it in
the first place he talks about you know
people say a lot of people are willing
to sacrifice you know pleasure happiness
he says yeah nineteen twentieth of the
population routinely have to do this
because of the kind of work that they're
stuck doing so what would afford the
possibility for people to not skip in
and not miss out on the development of
their intellectual and moral faculties
well education would have to play a role
in that and you might say also a
reorganization of society including the
the economy interestingly this probably
applies almost as much in our own time
as it did in Mills own time in the heart
of the Industrial Revolution when many
people were sinking into well you know
what later would be called the
proletariat or working-class and many
people were working very late hours
children were you know getting drawn
into the workplace rather than being
afforded the possibility for education
even if we have educational institutions
they may not be of the sort that do in
fact lead to effective moral and
intellectual development in which case
mill would say from utilitarian
perspective what is really desirable is
to rework them so that that does become
a possibility for everybody so he's
talking about the opportunity for human
development distinctively
human development not merely to satisfy
lower pleasures which are in fact
pleasures he's not saying though they're
bad at all but to afford the possibility
of higher pleasures this becomes a duty
from a utilitarian perspective if we
take quality into account
you